from Air apparent to opposition leader
Anu ibrahim's long career in politics
has culminated in him being sworn in as
prime minister of Malaysia
I Anwar Ibrahim to solemnly sweat
perform my duty as prime minister
sincerely and to the best of my ability
along the way he was twice imprisoned
for sodomy charges widely seen as
politically motivated
his first imprisonment sparked Street
protests and led to the birth of a
reform movement
upon his release he United the
opposition parties and turned the
Coalition into a formidable political
opponent he was jailed a second time two
years after he led the opposition to its
biggest electoral gains in 2013.
anwar's Alliance of Hope won the largest
number of seats in Saturday's elections
but fell short of a majority
his biggest rival is muyadin Yasin who
leads the second largest block made up
of a right-wing Malay Centric party and
a religiously conservative party
days of negotiations failed to produce a
coalition with majority support the
political impasse was only broken when
the king Al Sultan Abdullah appointed
anwa after speaking to several MPS this
is a national Unity government
all are welcome on condition you accept
the fundamental rules of good Governors
no corruption and Malaysia for all
religions
supporters say they welcome anwar's
appointment the multi-ethnic Coalition
is seen as more reform-minded and
liberal
I'm happy we've waited too long for this
and it's time for us to receive someone
who can give a better commitment to
Malaysia analysts say there will be no
honeymoon period for the new government
he has to put in place a cabinet that
conveys credibility and competence at
the same time he has to probably face a
challenge very soon in order to prove
that he has majority support in
Parliament
his rival muyidin Yasin has challenged
Anwar to prove his level of support
muyidin has also refused the king's
proposal the two sides set up a Unity
government Anu Ibrahim faces challenging
weeks and months ahead he'll have to
introduce reforms to fix the economy
he'll also be leading a country where
the racial and religious divides appear
to have deepened Florence Louis Al
Jazeera Kuala Lumpur